The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK, so kind of
a few things in mind for today.
One is to answer those two
questions on the second line.
We found those two formulas
on the first line last time,
the derivative of a inverse.
So the derivative of A
squared ought to be easy.
But if we can't do that,
we need to be sure we can.
And then this was the
derivative of an eigenvalue.
And then it's natural to
ask about the derivative
of the singular value.
And I had a happy day
yesterday in the snow,
realizing that that
has a nice formula too.
Of course, I'm not the first.
I'm sure that Wikipedia
already knows this formula.
But it was new to me.
And I should say Professor
Edelman has carried it
to the second derivative.
Again, not new, but it's
more difficult to find
second derivatives,
and interesting.
But we'll just stay
with first derivatives.
OK, so that's my
first item of sort
of business from last time.
And then I'd like to say
something about the lab
homeworks and ask your advice
and begin to say something
about a project.
And then I will move to
these topics in Section 4.4
that you have already.
And you might notice
I skipped 4.3.
And the reason is
that on Friday,
actually arriving
at MIT tomorrow
is Professor Townsend,
4.3 is all about his work.
And he's the best
lecturer I know.
He was here as an instructor
and did 18.06 and was
a big success.
Actually, he's also
just won a prize
for the SIAG/LA, international
prize for young investigators,
young faculty in
applied linear algebra.
So he goes to Hong Kong
to get that prize too.
Anyway, he will be on the videos
and in here in class Friday,
if all goes well.
OK, so in order
then, the first thing
is the derivative of A squared.
And you might think it's
2A dA dt, but it's not.
And if you realize
that it's not,
then you realize what it is,
you will get these things right
in the future.
So the answer to the derivative
of A squared is not 2A dA dt.
And why isn't it?
And what is the right answer?
So I do that maybe
just below here.
Well, I could ask you to
guess the right answer,
but why don't we do
it systematically.
So how do you find
the derivative?
It's a limit.
First you have a delta A, right.
And then you take a limit.
So I look at A plus delta
A squared minus A squared.
So that's the
change in A squared.
And I divide it by delta t.
And then delta t goes to 0.
So that's the derivative
I'm looking for,
the derivative of A squared.
And now, if I write that out,
you'll see why this is wrong,
but something very close to it,
of course-- can't be far away--
is right.
So what happens if
I write this out?
The A squared will
cancel the A squared.
What will I have?
Will I have 2A delta A?
Why don't I write
2A delta A next?
Because when you're squaring
a sum of two matrices,
one term is A delta A, and
another term is delta A A.
And those are
different in general.
And then plus delta A squared.
And now I divide
it all by delta t.
So you're now seeing my point
that now I let delta t go to 0.
So I'm just doing
matrix calculus.
And it's not altogether simple,
but if you follow the rules,
it comes out right.
So now what answer do I
get as delta t goes to 0?
I get A dA dt--
that's the definition of the--
that ratio goes to dA dt.
That's the whole idea
of the derivative of A.
And now what's the other term?
It's dA dt A. So it
was simply that point
that I wanted you to pick up on,
that the derivative might not
commute with A. Matrices
don't commute in general.
And so you'll notice that we
had a similar expression there.
We had to pay attention to
the order of things there.
And now we get it right.
It's not this, but A
dA dt plus dA dt A. OK.
Good.
Now, can I do the other one?
Which is a little more serious,
but it's a beautiful formula.
And it's parallel to this guy.
You might even guess it.
So I'm looking for the
derivative of a singular value.
The matrix A is changing.
dA dt tells me how it's changing
at the moment, at the instant.
And I want to know how is sigma
changing at that same instant.
And sort of in parallel
with this is a nice--
the nice formula--
u transpose dA dt v of t.
Boy, you couldn't ask for a
nicer formula than that, right?
You remember this
is the eigenvector.
And that's the eigenvector
of A transpose.
So this is the
singular vector of A.
And you could say this is a
singular vector of A transpose,
or it's the left singular vector
of A. So that's our formula.
And if we can just
recall how to prove it,
which is going to be parallel
to the proof of that one,
then I'm a happy person and
we can get on with life.
So let's remember this,
because it will help us
to remember the other one, too.
OK, so where do I start?
I start with a
formula for sigma.
So I believe that sigma is
u transpose times A times
v. Everybody agree with that?
Everything's depending
on t in this formula.
As time changes,
everything changes.
But I didn't write
in the parentheses,
t three more times.
Can we just remember
about the SVD.
The SVD says that
A times v equals--
AUDIENCE: Sigma u.
GILBERT STRANG: Sigma u.
Thanks.
Av is sigma u.
That's the SVD.
So when I put in for
Av, I put in sigma u.
Sigma is just a number.
So I bring it outside.
And I'm left with u transpose u.
And what's u transpose u?
1.
So I've used these two facts.
Or I could have
gone the other way
and said that this
is the transpose of--
this is A transpose u transpose.
I could look at it
that way times v.
And if I look at
it that way, I'm
interested in what
is A transpose u.
And what is A transpose u?
It's sigma v. And it's
transpose, so sigma v
transpose v.
And what is sigma v transpose v?
AUDIENCE: Sigma.
GILBERT STRANG: It's
sigma again, of course.
Got sigma both ways.
OK.
Now, I'm ready to
take the derivative.
That's the formula
I have for sigma,
completely parallel
to the formula
that we started out
with for lambda.
The eigenvalue was
y transpose Ax.
And now we've got
u transpose Av.
And, by the way, when
would those two formulas
be one and the same?
When does the SVD just
tell us nothing new
beyond the eigenvalue stuff for
what matrices are the singular
values, the same as the
eigenvalues, and singular
vectors the same as this
as the eigenvectors for--
For?
AUDIENCE: Symmetric.
GILBERT STRANG: Symmetric, good.
Symmetric, square,
and-- the two words
that I'm always looking
for in this course.
If you want an A in
this course, just
write down positive definite
in the answer to any question,
because sigmas are by
definition positive.
And if they're going to agree
totally with the lambdas,
then the lambdas
have to be positive.
Or could be 0, so positive
semidefinite definite
would be the right answer.
Anyway, this is our start.
And what do we do
with that formula?
So this was all the same,
because v transpose v was 1.
Here I had v transpose
v. And that's 1.
So it gave me sigma.
Yeah, good.
Everybody's with us.
OK, what do I do?
Take the derivative.
Takes the derivative of
that equation in the box.
It's exactly what
I did last time
with the corresponding
equation for lambda.
Same thing.
And I'm going to get again--
it's a product rule, because
I have three things multiplied
on the right-hand side.
So I've got three terms
from the product rule.
So d sigma dt,
coming from the box,
is du transpose dt Av
plus u transpose dA dt v
plus the third guy, which
will be u transpose A dv dt.
Did I get the three terms there?
Yep.
And which term do I want?
Which term do I believe is going
to survive and be the answer?
Well, this is what I'm after.
So it's the middle term.
The middle term is just right.
And the other two terms
had better be zero.
So that will be the proof.
The other two
terms will be zero.
So can we just take
one of those two terms
and show that it's
zero like this one?
OK, what have I got here?
I want to know that
that term is 0.
So what have I got.
I've got du transpose
dt times Av.
And everybody says, OK, in
place of Av, write in sigma u.
And sigma's a number, so I
don't mind putting it there.
So I've got sigma, a number of
times the derivative of u times
u itself, the dot product--
the derivative of u
with dot product with u.
And that equals?
0, I hope, because of this.
Because of that.
This comes from the
derivative of that.
But you see, now we've got
dot products, ordinary dot
products, and a number
on the right-hand side.
We're in dimension
1, you could say.
So this tells me immediately
that the derivative
of u with u plus u transpose
times the derivative of u
is the derivative
of 1, which is 0.
All I'm saying is that
these are the same.
You know, vectors, x transpose
y is the same as y transpose
x when I'm talking
about real numbers.
If I was doing complex
things, which I could do,
then I'd have to pay attention
and take complex conjugates
at the right moment.
But let's not bother.
So you see, this is
just two of these.
And it gives me 0.
So that term's gone.
And similarly, totally
similarly, this term is gone.
This is A transpose
u, all transpose.
I'm just doing the
same thing times dv dt.
And what is A transpose u?
It's sigma v. So this is
sigma v transpose dv dt.
And again 0, because of this.
So in a way this was a
slightly easier thing--
the last time was completely
parallel computation.
But the first and third terms
had to cancel each other with
the x's and y's.
Now, they disappear separately,
leaving the right answer.
You might think, how did
we get into derivatives
of singular values?
Well, I think if we're
going to understand the SVD,
then the first derivative
of the sigma is--
well, except that I've
survived all these years
without knowing it.
So you could say it's not--
you can live without it, but
it's a pretty nice formula.
OK, that completes
that Section 3.1.
And more to say about 3.2,
which was the interlacing
part that I introduced.
OK, so where am I?
I guess I'm thinking about the
neat topics about interlacing
of eigenvalues.
So may I pick up on that theme,
interlacing of eigenvalues
and say what's in the notes
and what's the general idea?
OK.
So we're leaving the
derivatives and moving
to finite changes in the
eigenvalues and singular
values, and we are
recognizing that we
can't get exact
formulas for the change,
but we can get
bounds for change.
And they are pretty cool.
So let me remind you what
that is, what they are.
So I have a matrix--
let's see, a symmetric
matrix S that
has eigenvalues lambda 1,
greater equal lambda 2,
greater equal so on.
Then I change S by some amount.
I think in the notes there is
a number, theta times 1 matrix.
That has eigenvalues mu
1, greater equal mu 2,
greater equal something.
And these are what I can't
give you an exact formula for.
You just would have
to compute them.
But I can give you
bounds for them.
And the bounds come
from the lambdas.
So this was a positive.
This is a positive change.
So the eigenvalues will
go up, or stay still,
but they won't go down.
So the mu's will be
bigger than the lambdas.
But the neat thing is that mu
2 will not pass up lambda 1.
So here is the interlacing.
Mu 1 is greater equal lambda 1.
That says that the highest
eigenvalue, the top eigenvalue
went up, or didn't move.
But mu 2 is below lambda 1.
This is the new--
everybody's with me here?
This is a new, and
this is the old.
New and old being old is S,
new is with the change in S.
And that mu 2 is
greater equal lambda 2.
So the second
eigenvalues went up.
And then so on.
That's a great fact.
And I guess that I sent
out a puzzle question.
Did it arrive in email?
Did anybody see that puzzle
question and think about it?
It worried me for a while.
Suppose this is the
second eigenvalue value--
eigenvector.
So I'm adding on, I'm hyping
up the second eigenvector,
hyping up the matrix
in the direction
of the second eigenvector.
So the second
eigenvalue was lambda 2.
And its mu 2, the new
second eigenvalue,
is going to be bigger by theta.
But then I lost a little
sleep in thinking, OK,
if the second eigenvalue
is mu 2 plus theta--
sorry, if the second
eigenvalue mu 2--
so let me write it here.
If mu 2, the second eigenvalue,
is the old lambda 2 plus theta
then bad news, because theta
can be as big as I want.
It can be 20, 200, 2,000.
And if I'm just adding theta
to lambda 2 to get the second--
because it's a second
eigenvector that's
getting pumped up, then after a
while, mu 2 will pass lambda 1.
This will be totally true.
I have no worries about this.
The old lambda 1--
actually, the old--
I'll even have
equality here, because
for this particular change,
it's not affecting lambda 1.
So I think mu 1
would be lambda 1
in my hypothetical possibility.
What I'm trying to
get you to do is
to think through what this
means, because it's quite
easy to write that line there.
But then when you think about
it, you get some questions.
And it looks as
if it might fail,
because if theta is really
big, that mu 2 would pass up
lambda 1.
And the thing would fail.
And there has to be a catch.
There has to be a catch.
So does anybody-- you
saw that in the email.
And I'll now explain
what how I understood
that everything can work and I'm
not reaching a contradiction.
And here's my thinking.
So it's perfectly true that the
eigenvalue that goes with u2--
or maybe I should be calling
them x2, because usually I
call the eigenvectors x2--
it's perfectly true that mu
2, that that one goes up.
But what happens when
it reaches lambda 1?
Actually, lambda 1,
the first eigenvalue,
is staying put, because it's
not getting any push from this.
But the second eigenvalue is
getting a push of size theta.
So what happens when lambda
2 plus theta, which is mu 2--
mu 2 is lambda 2 plus theta--
what happens when it
comes up to lambda 1
and I start worrying
that it passes lambda 1?
Do you see what's
happening there?
What happens when mu 2 passes--
when mu 2, which is--
I'm just going to copy here--
it's the old lambda 2 plus
the theta, the number.
What happens when theta gets
bigger and bigger and bigger
and this hits this thing
and then goes beyond?
Just to see the logic here.
What happens is that this lambda
2 plus theta, which was mu 2,
mu 2 until they got here.
But what is lambda 2 plus
theta after it passes lambda 1?
It's lambda 1 now.
It passed up, so it's
the top eigenvalue
of the altered matrix.
And therefore, it's just fine.
It's out here.
No problem.
Maybe I'll just say it again.
When theta is big
enough that mu 2 reaches
lambda 1, if I increase
theta beyond that,
then this becomes not
mu 2 any more, but mu 1.
And then totally
everybody's happy.
I won't say more on that,
because that's just like a way
that I found to make me think,
what do these things mean?
OK, enough said on
that small point.
But then the main point
is, why is this true?
This interlacing, which is
really a nice, beautiful fact.
And you could
imagine that we have
more different perturbations
than just rank 1s.
So let me tell you the
inequality, so named
after the discoverer,
Weyl's inequality.
So his inequality is for
the eigenvalues of S plus T.
So T is the change.
S is where I start.
It has eigenvalues lambda.
But now, I'm looking at the
eigenvalues of S plus T.
So I'm making a change.
Over here, in my
little puzzle question,
that was T. It was
a rank 1 change.
Now I will allow other ranks.
So I want to estimate
lambdas of S plus t
in terms of lambdas
of S and lambdas of T.
And I want some
inequality sign there.
And it's supposed to be true
for any symmetric matrices,
symmetric S and T.
And then a totally
identical Weyl inequality--
actually, Weyl was
one of the people
who discovered singular values.
And when he did it, he
asked about his inequality.
And he found that it
still worked the way we've
found this morning earlier.
I haven't completed
that yet, because I
haven't told you which
lambdas I'm talking about.
So let me do that.
So now, I'll tell you
Weyl's inequality.
So S and T are symmetric.
And so the lambdas are real.
And we want to know--
we want to get them in order.
OK, so here it goes.
Weyl allowed the i-th eigenvalue
of S and the j-th eigenvalue
of T and figured out that this
was bounded by that eigenvalue
of S plus T. So that's
Weyl's great inequality,
which reduces to the
one I wrote here,
if I make the right choice--
yeah, probably, if
I take j equal to 1.
So you see the beauty of this.
It tells you about
any eigenvalues of S,
eigenvalues of T.
So I'm using lambdas here.
Lambda of S are the
eigenvalues of S.
I'm using lambda again for T
and lambda again for S plus T.
So you have to pay attention
to which matrix I'm
taking the eigenvalues out of.
So let me take j equal to 1.
And this says that
lambda i, because j is 1,
S plus T is less or equal to
lambda i of S plus lambda 1,
the top eigenvalue of T.
This is lambda max of T.
Do you see that that's totally
reasonable, believable?
That the eigenvalue
when I add on T-- let's
imagine in our minds
that T is positive.
T is like this thing.
This could be the T, example of
a T. It's what I'm adding on.
Then the eigenvalues go up.
But they don't pass that.
So that tells you how
much it could go up by.
So I guess that Weyl is giving
us a less than or equal here.
Less or equal to lambda 1--
so I'm taking i to be 1--
plus theta.
Yeah, so that any equality
I've written down there--
there's some playing around
to do to get practice.
And it's not so essential for
us to be like world grandmasters
at this thing, but
you should see it.
And you should also
see j equal to 2.
Why will j equal to
2 tell us something?
I hope it will.
Let's see what it tells us.
Lambda i plus 1 now-- j is 2--
of S plus T. So it's less
than or equal to lambda i of S
plus lambda 2 of T. I
think that's interesting.
And also, I think I also could
get lambda i plus i minus 1.
Let me write it and
see if it's correct.
Plus lambda i minus 1.
So those was add up to i plus 2.
Yeah, I guess lambda i
plus 1 plus lambda 1 of T.
That's what I got by taking--
yeah, did I do that right?
I'm taking j equal to 1.
No, well, I don't
think I got it right.
What do I want to do here to
get a bound on lambda i plus 1?
I want to take j equal to 2.
I should just be sensible
and plug in j equal to 2
and i equal to 1.
All I want to say is that Weyl's
inequality is the great fact
out of which all this
interlacing falls
and more and more, because
the interlacing is telling me
about neighbors.
And actually if I use Weyl for i
and j, different i's and j's, I
even learn about ones
that are not neighbors.
And I could tell you a
proof of Weyl's inequality.
But I'll save that
for the notes.
So I think maybe
that's what I want
to do about interfacing, just
to say what the notes have,
but not repeat it all in class.
So the notes have actually two
ways to prove this interlacing.
The standard way that every
mathematician would use
would be Weyl's inequality.
But last year,
Professor Rao, visiting,
found a nice argument
that's also in the notes.
It ends up with a graph.
And on that graph, you
can see that this is true.
So for what it's worth, two
approaches to this interlacing
and some examples.
But I really don't
want to spend our lives
on this eigenvalue topic.
It's a beautiful fact
about symmetric matrices
and the corresponding fact
is true for singular values
of any matrix, but let's
think of leaving it there.
So now, I'm moving on
to the new section.
The new section
involves something
called compressed sensing.
I don't know if you've
heard those words.
So these are all topics in
Section 4.4, which you have.
I think we sent it out
10 days ago probably.
OK, so first let me remember
what the nuclear norm is
of a matrix.
The nuclear norm a matrix is
the sum of the singular values,
the sum of the singular values.
So it's like the L1
norm for a vector.
That's a right way
to think about it.
And do you remember
what was special?
We've talked about
using the L1 norm.
It has this special property
that the ordinary L2
norm absolutely does not have.
What was it special
about the L1 norm?
If I minimize the L1 norm with
some constraint, like ab equal
b, what's special about the
solution, the minimum in the L1
norm?
AUDIENCE: Sparse.
GILBERT STRANG: Sparse, right.
Sparse.
So this is moving
us up to matrices.
And that's where compressed
sensing comes in.
Matrix completion comes in.
So matrix completion
would just be--
I mentioned-- so
this is completion.
And I'll remember
the words Netflix,
which made the problem famous.
So I have the matrix A, 3, 2,
question mark, question mark,
question mark, 1, 4,
6, question mark--
missing data.
And so I have to put
it in something there,
because if I don't put in
anything, then the numbers
I do know are useless,
because no row or no column
is complete.
So it just would give up.
Somebody that sent
me the data, 3 and 2
and didn't tell me a
ranking for the third movie,
I'd have to say,
well, I can't use it.
That's not possible.
So we need to think about there.
And the idea is that the numbers
that minimized the nuclear norm
are a good choice,
a good choice.
So that's just a connection here
that we will say more about,
but not--
we could have a whole
course in compressed sensing
and nuclear norm.
Professor Parrilo in course
6 is an expert on this.
But you see the point that--
so you remember v1
came from the 0 norm.
And what is the 0
norm of the vector?
Well, it's not a norm.
So you could say,
forget it, no answer.
But what do we
symbolically mean when
I write the 0 norm of a vector?
I mean the number of....?
Non-zeros.
The number of non-zeros.
This was the number of
non-zeros in the vector, in v.
But it's not a norm, because
if I take 2 times the vector,
I have the same number
of non-zeros, same norm.
I can't have the norm
of 2v equal the norm
of v. That would blow away
all the properties of norms.
So v0 is not a norm.
And then we move it to that sort
of appropriate nearest norm.
And we get v1.
We get the L1 norm,
which is the sum of--
everybody remembers that
this is the sum of the vi.
And you remember my pictures
of diamonds touching
planes at sharp points.
Well, that's what
is going on here.
That problem was
called basis pursuit.
And it comes back
again in this section.
So I minimize this norm
subject to the conditions.
Now, I'm just going to take
a jump to the matrix case.
What's my idea here?
My idea is that for a
matrix, the nuclear norm
comes from what?
What's the norm that
we sort of start with,
but it's not a norm?
And when I sort of take the--
because the requirements
for a norm don't fail--
they fail for what I'm
about to write there.
I could put A 0,
but I don't want
the number of non-zero entries.
That would be a good guess.
And probably in some
sense it makes sense.
But it's not the
answer I'm looking for.
What do you think is the 0 norm
of a matrix that is not a norm,
but when I pump it up to the
best, to the nearest good norm,
I get the nuclear norm?
So this is the question,
it's what is A0?
And it's what?
AUDIENCE: The rank.
GILBERT STRANG: The rank.
The rank of matrix
is the equivalent.
So I don't know about the zero.
Nobody else calls it A0.
So I better not.
It's the rank.
So again, the rank
is not a norm,
because if I double the matrix,
I don't double the rank.
So I have to move to a norm.
And it turns out to
be the nuclear norm.
And now, I'll just,
with one minute,
say it's the guess of some
people who are working hard
to prove it, that
the deep learning
algorithm of gradient
descent finds
the solution to the minimum
problem in the nuclear norm.
And we don't know if
that's true or not yet.
For related examples, like
this thing, it's proved.
For the exact problem of deep
learning, it's a conjecture.
So that's what in section 4.4.
But that word lasso, you
want to know what that is.
Compressed sensing,
I'll say a word about.
So that will be Monday after
Alex Townsend's lecture Friday.
So he's coming to
speak to computational
science students all over
MIT tomorrow afternoon.
I'll certainly go
to that, but then he
said he would come in and
take this class Friday.
So I'll see you Friday.
And he'll be here too.